Das geht in Richtung Bundestrojaner und Online-Durchsuchung. In dem Zusammenhang kommt es immer wieder diese Geschichte. Das ist also dieser Zugriff auf informationstechnische Systeme, wie es sich das Bundeskriminalamt und unser Innenminister wünschen. Das beinhaltet auch, dass man zum Beispiel Mobiltelefone, Handys ein bisschen manipuliert. Das heißt, eine kleine Software raufspielt und ein kleines Zusatzprogramm raufspielt, womit man dieses Handy dann in ein Abhörgerät verwandeln kann. Das heißt also, man legt das dann wohin.
Man kann es vielleicht mal allgemeiner sagen. Man muss jetzt mal konkret sich überlegen, ein Handy ist ein Computer und selbstverständlich kann man auch auf solche Handys, Spionage-Software aufbringen und dann etwa in so einem Modus fahren, dass es so tut, als wenn es aus wäre.
Also ein Telefon hat Software drauf und man kann auch zusätzlich Software installieren. Entweder wird halt die Vorhandene komplett ausgetauscht gegen eine manipulierte oder es wird eine zusätzliche aufgespielt.
Das bedeutet aber, dass du erstmal mein Telefon brauchst, um da Dinge mitzumachen. Also du kannst nicht in einer S-Bahn neben mir sitzen und mir irgendwas schicken, was ich nicht mitkriege.
So sollte es eigentlich nicht sein, aber es ist natürlich schon die Möglichkeit, moderne Handys haben sogenanntes Over-the-Air-Update, heißt das eine Funktion, wo also dann später auch mal die Netzbetreiber die Telefone einfach so updaten können, weil warum auch immer sie das machen wollen, wenn Software Updates, ja genau, aber wenn sozusagen der Netzbetreiber irgendwie ein neues Feature, eine neue Funktion auf das Telefon bringen will, was ein Software Update erfordert, dann können die das machen.
Du hast ja neulich diese SMS gekriegt, wo du so ja geklickt hast.
Das war die mit der Gehaltserhöhung.
Auf jeden Fall kurzum, also das ist keine komplette Urban Legend oder keine Spinnerei, es gibt tatsächlich so eine Software, die kann man auch kaufen. Ich sage jetzt nicht den Namen, weil muss ja nicht sein. Das ist auch nicht so toll die Software. Allerdings gibt es auch so ein paar Nebenwirkungen. Das geht jetzt nicht so ganz einfach. Das heißt, wenn man denn Gespräche aufbaut, die tauchen natürlich dann auch auf der Telefonrechnung auf. Man merkt, wie der Akku leer wird. Also es gibt schon Anzeichen dafür. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es komplett unbemerkt stattfindet. Und man muss irgendwie diese Software auch raufkriegen. Wenn ich jetzt gerade nicht Netzbetreiber bin, sondern irgendwie der eigentlich versüchtige Freund oder Freundin und mal wissen will, was mein Liebster oder mein Liebster da so tut, dann kann ich mir natürlich dieses Telefon schnappen. Aber dazu muss ich es eigentlich schon erstmal in die Hand bekommen.
Und wenn ich nicht möchte, dass sowas passiert, nehme ich einfach ein Akku raus.
Das ist eine Variante und hofft, dass nicht irgendjemand heimlich noch einen kleinen extra Akku wieder ins Telefon reingeschmuggelt hat. Aber das ist dann, also wie gesagt, der Paranoia Faktor kann da schon beliebig hoch werden. Aber also bei dringenden richtigen Besprechungen ist es schon so, dass die Handy am besten draußen bleiben.
Okay und damit sind wir jetzt im Blue Moon beim Thema Vorrats, Taschen und Ladensprecherungen, Internetverbindungen. Ich wähle mich in das Internet ein. Damit hatten wir vorhin schon mal Kriegner IP, also eine Nummer, die sozusagen meinem Anschluss zugeordnet ist von meinem Internet Provider, Firma Internet Dönikis, dann sagen kann, der Kranz war gestern Abend um 22.37 Uhr online, um zu gucken, wann der Bus fährt, weil er war bei rfbvg.de.
Genau und ganz wichtige Information zu wissen ist, dass bei den meisten Webseiten, also bei den meisten Servern, wird diese IP-Adresse auch gespeichert beim Zugriff. Das heißt also jeder Seitenabruf wird mit dieser IP-Adresse protokolliert. Das ist zwar eigentlich nicht legal, da gab es auch schon viel gezeter drum. Zum Beispiel haben Bundesbehörden speichern das auch. Da gab es dann auch ein Gerichtsverfahren, dass sie das jetzt nicht mehr speichern dürfen. Ich würde mal darauf wetten, dass die sich da einen Scheißdreck drum stören und scheren und es trotzdem weitermachen. Also bis auf die eine, die wir jetzt abgeschaltet haben, aber die anderen werden halt sagen, ja so what. Es gibt ja den jährlichen Big Brother Awards, also einen negativen Datenschutzpreis für die größten Datenkragen. Und da hat auch mal der in der Open Source Szene, glaube ich mit fast 50 Prozent Marktanteil, so einer der beliebtesten Web Server, der Apache Web Server hat auch mal einen Preis gekriegt, den Community Preis, also Kategorie Community, weil es einfach da standardmäßig eingeschaltet ist, dieses IP-Adressen mitloggen. Das heißt also, das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die nicht so toll ist, aber es ist standardmäßig da und eigentlich macht sich auch kaum jemand Gedanken. Die Leute finden es auch ganz interessant, die wollen mal wissen, wer kommt eigentlich so, woher kommen die Leute. Es ist so ein bisschen so diese Neugier, so wie das, ich würde am liebsten gerne irgendwie eine Webcam irgendwie beim Nachbarn durchs Fenster richten und mal schauen, was der dann so im Wohnzimmer treibt.
Das heißt, das ist der Punkt, an dem natürlich die Leute, die sich sehr dafür interessieren, also Musikindustrie, Filmindustrie, wo die dann sagen können, die üblichen Musik Download Portale, wie sie alle heißen, wer war da online, schickt mir noch mal bitte die IP-Daten, dann kann man nachprüfen, wer dann da drauf war und dann kriegt ihr Post oder auch nicht.
Genau, oder wie zum Beispiel ich mit dem Bundeskriminalamt und setze mal eine Seite auf, die ganz interessant ist. Ups, das Studio fällt auseinander. Ich hoffe, es war nichts Wichtiges.
Naja, jedenfalls hat man sich überlegen muss dabei ist natürlich, dass diese Forderungen schon offiziell gemacht wurden. Also etwa gibt es die schriftlich vom Bundesrat, der es gerne wollte und vor wenigen Tagen hat sich tatsächlich unser Kulturstaatsminister, der Herr Neumann, offiziell dazu geäußert und gesagt, ja, diese Daten müsste man der Content der Musikindustrie dann mal zur Verfügung stellen.
Genau, vielleicht noch ganz kurz, also BKA, die haben folgendes gemacht, die haben eine Webseite aufgesetzt. Da ging es irgendwie, es war eine Informationsseite zur militanten Gruppe. Also man behauptet eine terroristische Vereinigung, es ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung. Und man hat also einfach die IP-Adressen von den Leuten mitprotokolliert, die diese Seite besucht haben, haben gedacht, naja, wenn Sie sich dafür interessieren, dann sind es doch mal hier unsere potenziellen Verdächtigen. Und haben dann quasi mittels der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sie hieß noch nicht so, aber es ist natürlich so, auch dass die Internet-Provider die IP-Adressen auch bisher schon gespeichert haben, eine Weile, noch nicht so lange. Aber die meisten haben das verbotenerweise, meistens verbotenerweise trotzdem gemacht. Dann ist man zu denen gegangen und sagt, okay, wir essen das jetzt hier und haben den Leuten mal eine Hausdurchsuchung gemacht. Weil es war ja schon verdächtig genug, dass die da auf der Webseite waren und sich dafür interessiert haben.
Soviel zum Prinzip, was da alles funktioniert, wie sowas mitgeloggt werden kann. Wie habe ich als Privatperson eine Chance, diese Spuren zu verschleiern, zu verschlüsseln? Damit sind wir bei Dingen, die wir ansprechen wollten, wie Tor, wie JAP, also Verschlüsselungsprogramme.
Also Tor ist halt eine gute Möglichkeit.
Was ist Tor?
Tor ist der sogenannte Tor-Onion-Router, also das ist die Abkürzung dafür quasi und es hat eine sehr populäre Methode. Also eine der gängigsten in Deutschland. Es gibt noch ein anderes Projekt, nämlich JAP, also ein Konkurrenzprojekt quasi. Man kann ja mehrere Methoden verwenden und hiermit kann man sich also effektiv dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung entziehen.
Was machen diese Programme?
Also Tor, Tor-Onion-Router, also Zwiebel kommt also von diesem Zwiebelschalen.
Das ist schön, da hat man die schöne kleine Zwiebel unten im Browser.
Und die Idee ist, dass also wie bei diesen Zwiebelschalen, also viele Schichten hintereinander, ist also so, dass die Kommunikationsdaten da von einem Server zum nächsten verschleiert werden.
Es wird also keine direkte Verbindung mehr zwischen dem Kunden, also mir als Server und dem Server mehr hergestellt.
Das heißt der Server weiß nicht mehr, dass du dich da einloggst, sondern die Anfrage kommt von irgendwo aus Papua originär.
Genau und es gibt irgendwie, jetzt muss ich kurz zu Konstanzen rüber gucken, ich glaube drei oder fünf sind immer in so einer Kette. Man kann es glaube ich auch einstellen.
Unterschiedlich, ja man kann es teilweise auch einstellen. Es gibt einige Software, die man sozusagen nicht dazu installieren kann bei dem Betriebssystem, wo man auch sehen kann, auch grafisch teilweise jetzt schon, wo die Route langgeht. Also es werden quasi andere Server ausgesucht, über die dann geroutet wird.
Diese Server oder diese Tor-Server in dem Sinne sind es ja nicht. Es sind ja Vermittlungsstellen oder Weiterleitungsrechner. Die sollten natürlich möglichst gut verteilt sein. Diese Server werden, dieser Dienst wird von, ja in der Regel Organisationen, teilweise Privatpersonen bereitgestellt, die es wichtig ist, dass da Privatsphäre beim Internet-Surfen gewahrt wird. Der Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel betreibt sowas. Aber auch, ja, Filbo oder angeschlossene Organisationen in den USA, gibt es viele Organisationen, also die stehen schon in einigen Ländern, weil es einfach schon genug Leute gibt, die auch den Nutzen von diesen Dingern erkannt haben. Ein Beispiel ist auch mal, wenn man jetzt Zensurbestrebungen in einem Land umgehen, oder Zensurmaßnahmen, Stichwort China, dann ist also so ein Dienst natürlich Gold wert.
Und innerhalb also dieser Schichten wird natürlich verschlüsselt, sodass auch im Nachhinein die Verbindung nicht rückwärts wieder aufgerollt werden kann.
Das klingt nach, wenn man über Vorratsdatenspeicherung redet, und wir hatten ja gerade bei Mails und so, gibt es nicht wirklich eine Chance. Das klingt jetzt nach der eierlegenden Wollmilchsau, die den einzigen Nachteil hat, dass die Internetverbindung ein bisschen langsamer wird, weil es ja über mehrere verschiedene Ecken geht und einfach länger unterwegs ist.
Ja, kann man wohl grundsätzlich so sagen. Natürlich muss man eine Unbequemlichkeit entkaufen, das ist nämlich genau die angesprochene Geschwindigkeit. Ich persönlich habe dafür eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit gefunden, da ich ohnehin im Browser immer recht viele Taps auf dem Hab, also es ist häufig halt immer mehrere Taps. Also mich persönlich stört es nicht so. Wenn man es jetzt erstmalig benutzt, wird man sicherlich sich wundern, wenn man sich so ein bisschen ins Modem-Zeitadter zurückversetzt fühlt. Und man hat manchmal Probleme, dadurch dass man die sogenannten Exit-Notes, also die Knoten, die aus dem Netzwerk herausführen, die kann man filtern und es gibt einige Seiten im Internet, die diese auch tatsächlich filtern. Also da gibt es manchmal schon Probleme, dann muss man halt manchmal seine Identität einmal wechseln. Das ist möglich mit der Software. Manchmal auch zwei, dreimal.
Funktioniert JAP genauso? Also ohne jetzt ins ganz tiefe technische Detail zu gehen, also TOR ist ganz einfach, nicht mehr der direkte Weg von mir zum Server, der dann nachvollziehbar ist, sondern es geht über drei oder vier Punkte.
In so einem Schalenprinzip.
Oder nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Billard und du weißt plötzlich nicht mehr, von welcher Bande kommt eigentlich die Kugel. So ähnlich funktioniert das?
Ja, insofern ist JAP natürlich vergleichbar. JAP ist ein Projekt der Uni Dresden. Und auch lange gefördert. Also hier in Deutschland, also mit öffentlichen Mitteln gefördert. Das ist ein ähnliches Prinzip. Natürlich, man muss überlegen.
Also steht auch im Telemedien, Teledienstegesetz steht, dass also auch eine anonyme oder eine pseudonyme Nutzung von Telediensten möglich sein muss. Und wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die IP-Adresse wirklich meiner Person dann auch zugeordnet ist, wenn vielleicht nicht für den Anbieter ersichtlich, aber insgesamt doch irgendwie eine Zuordnung möglich ist. Oder gerade wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel an der Uni ist, dann haben die Rechner in diesen Pools oftmals feste IP-Adressen. Das heißt also, man kann wirklich sehr gut feststellen oder in Büros, Mitarbeiterbüros, teilweise immer noch öffentliche IP-Adressen. Das heißt, sie sind dann auch wirklich einer Person zugeordnet.
Naja, das ist vielleicht auch mal eine Sache, die wir aber mal auch mal prinzipiell ansprechen sollen. Die Vorstellung, die viele Leute haben, ganz egal, was Frank jetzt meint, was natürlich richtig ist, die Vorstellung, dass man eine IP-Adresse erstmal prinzipiell einer Person zuordnen kann, ist natürlich nicht immer gegeben. Zunächst mal kann man damit, wenn man Glück hat, einen Rechner identifizieren. Nicht aber sehen, wer da wirklich sitzt.
Genau, weil du hast ein offenes WLAN, was ist sicherlich auch eine Kneipe, die hat ein offenes WLAN da. Und ich weiß zwar irgendwie, zu welcher Kneipe der Anschluss gehört, aber nicht ob jetzt Heinz, Peter oder Erwin da sitzen.
Oder es zeigt auf eine Note, also intern hängen da noch mehrere Rechner dran. All dies ist möglich, das ist oft so eine, das hört man von Politikern, die jetzt nun technisch ja meistens nicht so, die hören man halt auf das DIP.
Was war nochmal ein Browser?
Jaja genau, die Internetausdrucke.
Wobei es also schon so ist, dass diese Zuordnung natürlich erstmal gemacht wird. Das heißt also, wenn du ein offenes WLAN bei dir hast, dann bist du derjenige, der irgendwie morgens vom SEK aus dem Bett geklingelt wird.
Und du musst dann erklären, was da eigentlich los war. Okay, dann nachdem wir das jetzt so ein bisschen eingeordnet haben, seid ihr jetzt wieder dran? 0331 70 97 110. Michaela aus Münster ist am Telefon, die im weitesten Sinne eine Internetfrage hat. Hallo Michaela. Du hast bis jetzt nicht zu gestinkigt, weil du eine Weile warten musstest.
Ist nicht so schlecht.
Wir mussten das ja. Deine Frage bezieht sich auch aufs Internet, wird aber doch ziemlich speziell. Schieß mal los.
Ja genau, und zwar habe ich eine Spielekonsole seit über einem Jahr und darüber kam man auch ins Internet über Weißland. Und da habe ich, ja genau, ne, ja doch, das ist richtig. Ja ich wusste nicht ob man es sagen darf.
Es gibt noch Wo und Was und Wer und alles mögliche.
Gut, ne, auf jeden Fall bin ich damit ins Internet gegangen, über eine Suchmaschine auch. Und hab dann was bestimmtes eingegeben, weil ich was gesucht habe und auf einmal stand da mein eBay-Name, obwohl ich den noch nie da eingegeben hatte. Also da war ich auch total geschockt.
Ach so, warte mal, aber du hast...
Wo stand der in der Suchmaschine?
Ich hab es auch noch nicht so ganz verstanden, ehrlich gesagt.
Du hast dich bei eBay angemeldet und dein eBay-Name stand schon drin.
Nein, nein, also ich hab nur übers Internet, bei Google zum Beispiel, hab ich was eingegeben. Ich wollte eigentlich zu einem besonderen Markt, also DB-Markt heißt es ja, und dann zeigte mir Google auf einmal meinen eBay-Namen, aber auch den Markt, der da für zuständig ist. Also da, wo ich eigentlich gucken wollte. Aber da stand mein eBay-Namen drüber.
Das klingt ein bisschen komisch. Ich wüsste jetzt erstmal auf Anhieb nicht, wie das zustande kommt, ehrlich gesagt.
Im Zweifelsfall einen anderen eBay-Account anlegen.
Also ich mein, vielleicht hast du irgendeinen Bekannten, der einen eigenen E-Mail-Server betreibt oder jemand, der so quasi mal technisch so einrichten kann, dass du auf einem, also zu Hause, man kann ja auch auf seinem PC einen Web-Server relativ schnell einrichten, also zumindest unter Windows, wahrscheinlich Mac auch unter der Linux. Aber dass du dann mal mit dieser V auf die Webseite gehst und ihr dann mal gemeinsam in das Protokoll rein guckt, ob vielleicht diese Spielekonsole irgendwelche komischen Daten mitschickt.
Also ich würde das machen, da wäre ich jetzt schon neugierig. Ehrlich gesagt hat mir noch nie jemand so einen Fall erzählt. Also das würde ich echt gerne mal prüfen lassen. Kannst du uns ja dann mal in die Mail schicken und sagen, was rausgekommen ist.
Also wende dich vertrauensvoll an deinen zuständigen Alphanart.
Also können wir hier am Radio jetzt auch nicht klären.
Ja ist okay, gut, war nur eine Frage.
Aber spannende Geschichte, danke für den Einwand. Nächster am Telefon ist Tom aus Berlin. Hallo Tom, guten Abend.
Ja und zwar, ich hab zwei Fragen. Eins betrifft auch so was, was mit Google zu tun hat. Und zwar über Google hört man ja immer alles Mögliche, so von wegen was die mit den Daten so machen.
So was hört man denn da?
Überwiegend ungute Sachen, vor allem aus dem Ausland jetzt. China fällt mir da spontan ein, dass sie da massenweise Daten verkaufen. Und wenn man weiß, wie die Chinesen damit umgehen, dann ist es natürlich nicht so schön. Und meine Frage ist einfach, wenn ich jetzt bei Google zum Beispiel was eingebe, Suchbegriff, was auch immer, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass die, also dass sie es speichern, davon gehe ich ehrlich gesagt aus, aber wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass es auch weiterverwendet wird?
Von wem weiterverwendet? Von Google oder von Behörden möglicherweise?
Ja, im Prinzip egal. Also wäre Google dazu quasi in der Lage, das an Dritte entweder zu verkaufen, so Marketing-technisch, oder wären die dazu verpflichtet, sozusagen das an Behörde weiterzugeben?
Also wenn Tom, um den Fall zu konstruieren, weil wir sind ja immer noch bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wenn Tom bei Google eingebt, er interessiert sich für, wir sagen mal, Ledergeschirre für seinen Chihuahua-Pudel, ist dann Google unter anderem in der Lage, nicht nur zuzuordnen, dass sich da jeder, dass Tom sich sozusagen dafür interessiert und das auch noch weitergeht? Also ist Tom mit der Anfrage identifizierbar?
Bisschen handfester vielleicht noch, die Behörden gehen zu Google und sagen, der Tom war am Samstag von 14 bis 16 Uhr mit der IP-Adresse eingewählt und wir wollen jetzt mal wissen, was er in der Zeit alles bei Google nachgeguckt hat. Das ist technisch überhaupt kein Problem. Ob Google jetzt so die Daten so einfach rausrückt, weiß ich nicht. Es wird schon noch was vorliegen müssen, also zumindest eine Anordnung. Aber im Prinzip spricht dann nichts dagegen, dass Google, wenn sie diese Daten haben, die dann auch rausrücken muss.
Also klar muss einem natürlich dabei prinzipiell sein, dass Google keine Suchmaschine ist. Sollte einem immer klar sein, sondern dass Google ein großer Datensammler ist. Und vollkommen klar ist aber natürlich auch, dass Google also auf jeden Fall aufhebt, weil das ist der Zweck der Unternehmung, dass sie alles das, was gesucht wird, eben abspeichern.
Und dann noch...
Genau, da war eine zweite Frage.
Also, genau, und zwar Google Maps zum Beispiel. Wenn ich jetzt häufiger, ja, da Adressen suche und so weiter, dann ist Google natürlich auch daran interessiert, dass, also das irgendwie zu speichern, denke ich mal, um sich irgendwie mein Profil noch besser irgendwie anlegen zu können. Und wenn man jetzt, wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, dass Handy geortet wird und so weiter in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das würde dann quasi auch einfach weitergegeben werden, theoretisch.
Handyortung hat direkt nicht so viel mit, ist nur ein kleiner Bruchteil von Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau, genau, aber dass man quasi, lieber Google, du meinst Google Maps?
Oder meinst du jetzt Google Maps? Also es gibt ja auch jetzt die Funktion auf Mobiltelefon, dass ich mich da drüber orten lassen kann.
Das wäre jetzt quasi, das wäre als nächstes so, wenn man jetzt sich ein neues tolles Handy kauft, dann hat man ja mittlerweile auch ab und zu die Funktion, dass man da eingebautes Navi und so weiter hat. Ein guter Freund von mir, der benutzt das, der klemmt sich das dann immer auf sein Fahrrad vorne dran und fährt damit durch die Stadt. Wäre es quasi ohne Weiteres möglich, seine komplette Route durch ganz Berlin nachzuvollziehen, was er so am Tag macht und wo er hinfährt?
Also vielleicht ein kleines Missverständnis oder eine kleine Richtestellung zu GPS. Also GPS ist eine reine Einweggeschichte. Das heißt also GPS ist immer nur vom Satelliten zu uns runter. Wenn nicht das Gerät selbst irgendwelche Daten wieder wohin sendet, also das ist ein Einschränk. Aber rein GPS, also wenn ich jetzt einfach nur ein Navigationsgerät hab, ohne Handy drinnen oder irgendwelchen anderen Schnickschnack, was irgendwo hin telefoniert, dann ist GPS eine reine Einweggeschichte. Also nur anhand davon, dass ich ein GPS-Gerät hab, kann ich jetzt erstmal nicht geortet werden.
Genau, aber wenn ich jetzt mit dem Handy das quasi mache, dann muss ich auch erstmal die Anfrage schicken, nämlich die Adresse an den Satelliten schicken, der mir dann irgendwie sagt, wie ich da hinkomme oder so, oder?
Nee, du schickst es nicht, sondern der bekommt die Daten, die Positionsdaten. Allerdings ist es so, wenn das Handy eingeschaltet ist, dass es das gleiche wie auch bei der Lkw-Maut, bei diesen Onboard-Units, die in den Lkws drin sind, da ist einfach ein Handy drin. Alles, was ein Handy hat, ist auch ein Peilsender gleichzeitig. Also einfach immer technisch bedingt, muss ein Handy immer seine aktuelle Position an das Netz übermitteln, damit das Netz weiß, genau wo und welche Funkzelle. Also die aktuellen Mobilfunknetze sind ja so aufgebaut, dass man überall Masten hat. Je moderner die Netze, desto kleiner, engmaschiger ist dieses Netz, dass man kleinere Sendeleistungen braucht. Umso genauer muss das Netz auch wissen, wo das Telefon gerade angesprochen wird, wo es gerade erreicht wird.
Zu dem Thema würde ich gerne kurz einwerfen. Chaosradio.ccc.de Es gibt Podcasts zu den Sendungen, die auch in der Vergangenheit liefen. Unter anderem gab es eine großartige Sendung zum Thema wie funktioniert eigentlich das GPS-System bzw. wie funktioniert dieses Handy-System mit diesen ganzen Zellgeschichten.
Die Sendung war der GSM Podcast.
Genau. Kann man sich ziehen, anhören, Chaosradio.ccc.de und danach ist man schlauer. Ich sag's euch. Selbst ich hab's begriffen. Tschüss und grüß deinen Kumpel mit seinem komischen Navi auf der Fahrrad. Sag ihm, er soll mal über die Schulter gucken, bevor er bei Rot über die Ampel feuert. Tschüss. 0331 70 97 110. Das ist unsere Telefonnummer. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Teil 131. Wie immer am letzten Freitag im Monat. Zu Gast ist der Chaos Computer Club mit Konstanze, mit Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sind gerade so ein bisschen abgeschweift in die Handy-Ortung und solche Geschichten, waren aber eigentlich dabei, wie sicher ist meine Internetverbindung? Da gab es einen schönen Einwand. Kann Google eigentlich irgendjemand weiter erzählen, was ich bei denen gesucht habe und was kann ich machen, wenn ich das nicht will?
Gerade da ist dann auch so ein Anonymisierungsdienst wie Tor dann wieder eine ganz wichtige Sache, weil mit Tor wird ja dann auch mal eine Identität gegenüber Google verschleiert. Das heißt also, die können dann nicht sehen, welche IP-Adresse das wirklich war mit der Anfrage, sondern es ist dann immer nur wieder die letzte sogenannte Exit-Note von diesem Tor-Dienst oder diesem Tor-Netzwerk, was denn in den Protokollen von Google oder dem anderen Web-Server auftaucht. So und deswegen ist es auch ganz sinnvoll, wenn man, wenn man zum Beispiel in einer Firma ist und mal ein bisschen recherchieren will und dann nicht sofort will, dass dann die Firmen-IP-Adresse bei den anderen im Protokoll auftaucht, dann ist das auch mal eine ganz sinnvolle Anwendung dafür. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt nur wirklich, wenn ich jetzt konkret was zu verbergen hab, wenn ich jetzt mal ganz klar und heimlich vielleicht auf irgendwelchen Schmuddelseiten rumsurfen will, sondern das ist eigentlich wirklich eine Sache, die im täglichen Einsatz ist. Und ja, je mehr Leute das auch gleichzeitig benutzen, desto mehr rauschen, desto mehr nutzlose Daten entstehen natürlich auch. Und dementsprechend wird es dann auch immer schwierig zu schauen, ob dann jetzt wirklich vielleicht jemand was zu verbergen hat. Das ist ja bei der Verschlüsselung immer so, wenn ich jetzt pro Tag 30 Mails schicke und davon nur eine verschlüsselte, dann liegt natürlich die Vermutung nahe, dass diese eine vielleicht ganz besonders wichtig war. Wenn ich jetzt aber von 30 Mails 28 verschlüsselte, dann ist es dann nicht mehr so einfach zu sagen, die war es jetzt.
Wie das genau funktioniert, wie Tor funktioniert, wie JAP funktioniert, wie Mailsverschlüsselung funktionieren, fritz.de klicken, Marcos suchen, Marcos Richter hat das alles online gestellt. Wir haben gleich die Nachrichten, danach müssen wir noch reden über Asterisk.
Genau, wie man Telefonie verschleiern kann.
Das müssen wir noch klären. Und vorher ganz kurz noch die Frage von Lutz aus Oranienburg. Ich hoffe, Sie ist einfach zu beantworten. Hallo Lutz. Guten Abend.
Guten Abend. Also meine Frage ist, also ich bin ja im Besitz eines eigenen Rott-Servers und wollte fragen, da ich über den per Remote-Desktop öfter mal im Internet surfe und auf Seiten chatte und E-Mails verschicke, also auf den Server und dann weiter.
Ist das sicher?
Auf dem Server selber einen Web-Server, also Web-Space-Server, also auch in Domainservern alles drauf hab. Ist der gegen Angriffe von außen, also gegen irgendwelche Spionageaktivitäten da geschützt oder muss ich da auch irgendwie den registrieren lassen, da ja auch dort E-Mails viele geschrieben werden, da ich ja auch viele E-Mail-Adressen dort vergeben hab.
Na, geht es dir jetzt darum, ob, ja, um die Verbindungsdaten oder geht es dir um irgendwie Spionagesoftware jetzt?
Beides, also...
Na, weil die Verbindungsdaten betrifft, kommt es natürlich erst mal zunächst darauf an, wie du dich, wie verbindest du dich remote zudem?
Per Windows, also über Remote Desktop, dann über die Benutzerdaten logon und dann wirklich drauf auf dem Desktop des Servers.
Ah ja, und du willst quasi wissen, ob die Leute, die deinen Webserver benutzen, ob da möglich ist, deren Verbindung zu kriegen, ja? Also man muss schon sagen, dass du natürlich jetzt kleiner anbieter, du würdest jetzt unter die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gar nicht fallen. Das heißt, bei dir sind in gewisser Weise Leute insofern sicher, dass du nicht für den Start die Verbindungsdaten halten musst für die Leute, die sich auf deinem Rechner einloggen.
Wobei vielleicht ein ganz kurzer Einwurf dazu. Es gibt nämlich eine ganz ganz großartige Alternative zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Der Fachbegriff dafür ist Quick Freeze. Also schnelles Einfrieren und meint, dass wenn tatsächlich ein konkreter Verdacht vorliegt, dass die Behörden dann zum Provider gehen, sagen, jetzt hätten wir gern für diese Kennung mal alle Informationen gespeichert. Sozusagen ab jetzt einfrieren, aufbewahren. Wir holen uns die vielleicht in zwei Wochen ab, wenn das Ganze konkret geworden ist. Und das ist eine Sache, die dich dann natürlich auch treffen könnte. Also wenn jetzt einer deiner Benutzer auf deinem Server da irgendwie verdächtigt wird, irgendwelchen Mist zu machen, dann kann die Polizei natürlich schon und die Behörden können dann schon zu dir kommen, sagen, wir wollen jetzt gern mal da die Daten von dem haben.
Also du bist damit nicht in einem rechtsfreien Raum.
Genau.
Und du bist dann auch verpflichtet, dem User das dann nicht mitzuteilen.
Zumindest wäre es nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Genau.
Ich wüsste, um ehrlich zu sein, oh ja nicht, wie ich die Daten da rauskriege, die da gespeichert werden.
Im Zweifelsfall wissen die Behörden schon, wie es da ist.
Im Zweifelsfall nehmen die einfach den Server mit und die wissen es dann schon.
Aber ich muss den jetzt nicht hier die Login-Daten für, dass sie da selber remote irgendwie so...
Dann nochmal ganz deutlich, sie nehmen einfach deinen Rechner mit, wenn du ihnen die Daten nicht lieferst.
Nee, der steht nicht bei mir zu Hause, der steht irgendwo in Deutschland im großen Server-Center.
Ja, ist ja noch einfacher.
Also beschlagnahmt wird oft genau dort.
Wir haben das Spielchen im letzten Jahr schon ein paar Mal durch, da ging es eben darum, dass einfach diese Tor-Server beschlagnahmt worden sind. Und da konnten wir ein breites Spektrum an Erfahrungen sammeln, sei es bei Privatpersonen, wo die Leute zu Hause standen, wo das gemietete Server waren, wo das irgendwelche Root-Server waren, die irgendwo bei einem Billighoster waren. Also da kennen die auch keinen Schmerz und das geht dann ratzfatz. Aber wie gesagt, wenn sowas ist, sowieso Anwalt und alles sein geordneten Gang gelassen.
Du bist als so ein kleiner Privater, vermutlich auch nicht kommerzieller Anbieter, jetzt nicht unter diese neue Gesetzgebung gefallen. Das betrifft jetzt erstmal, ich glaube die Zahl war 1000.
Wobei 1000, also ist es auch noch nicht ganz klar, da warten wir jetzt auch noch mal auf eine Präzisierung. Also 1000 Kunden, 1000 Nutzer, das ist ja eine sehr variable Zahl. Also gerade wenn man jetzt sowas hat, wie ein Web-Server oder irgendwie einen kleinen Telefonievermittlungsdienst, weiß auch immer, was sind denn. Also wenn ich jetzt gar keine Kundenbeziehung habe, das ist ja klar, wenn ich jetzt von irgendwie 1500 Leuten im Monat 10 Euro bekomme, dann ist es klar, wie viele Kunden ich habe. Aber wenn ich jetzt eine Dienstleistung habe, wo jeder mal hingeht, mal vorbeischaut, dann ist es ja alles gar nicht so klar, wie viele Kunden da jetzt wirklich sind, ob ich da jetzt betroffen bin oder nicht.
Und wie das mit der Telefonie und der Verschlüsselung der Telefonie ist, das klären wir nach den Nachrichten.
Aufwenden auch, tschüss.
Die exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Konzerte gehen wieder, wieder weiter. Diesmal mit neuer Musik aus England. Fritz präsentiert Maximo Part. Kommen den Freitag, live in den Fritz-Studios und natürlich im Radio. Mehr Infos fritz.de Karten zum dabei sein gibt's nirgendwo. Außer im www.meinfritz.de Einfach suchen, finden und gewinnen. Und das hört man.
Vier nach halb zwölf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Liane Gruß.
Der seit zehn Monaten andauernde Tarifstreit zwischen der Bahn und den Lokführern ist zu Ende. Das haben beide Seiten am Abend in Berlin bestätigt. Der lange umkämpfte eigenständige Tarifvertrag soll am 1. März in Kraft treten und zehn Monate gelten. Die Lokführer bekommen damit Gehaltserhöhungen von 11 Prozent und eine Einmalzahlung von 800 Euro. Außerdem gilt ab Februar 2009 die 40-Stunden-Woche. Warnchef Medorn und GDL-Chef Shell wollen den Vertrag in der nächsten Woche unterschreiben. Der Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft der Polizei Freiberg hat eine Bestandsaufnahme aller privaten Waffen gefordert. Er bezeichnete es als Skandal, dass man zwar wisse, wie viele Bananen nach Deutschland eingeführt werden, aber nicht bekannt sei, wie viele Waffen es gibt. Im gleichen Zuge begrüßte er das Vorhaben der Großen Koalition künftig alle Anscheinwaffen, attrappen die echten Waffen nachempfunden sind, zu verbieten. Aber man sollte diese Waffen nicht nur verbieten, man müsste auch Bußgelder verhängen. Zwischen den Koalitionsparteien in Brandenburg ist ein Streit um einen landesweiten Mindestlohn entbrannt. Hintergrund ist der Vorschlag der SPD, öffentliche Aufträge nur noch an Unternehmen zu vergeben, die einen Mindestlohn von 7, 50 Euro zahlen. Dem RBB-Politikmagazin Klartext sagte Finanzminister Speer, die SPD versuche gegenwärtig die CDU davon zu überzeugen. Der Hamburger SV hat erstmals seit elf Jahren wieder das vierte Finale im DFB-Pokal erreicht. Die Hamburger siegten gegen Rot-Weiß-Essen 3 zu 0. Auch der VfB Stuttgart ist eine Runde weiter, nach einem 3 zu 2 Sieg gegen die zweite Mannschaft von Werder Bremen. Carl Zeiss Jena gewann gegen Arminia Bielefeld 2 zu 1 und erreichte damit ebenfalls das vierte Finale. Und auch der VfL Wolfsburg schaffte den Sprung in die nächste Runde. Er besiegte Schalke 04 nach Verlängerung und Elfmeterschießen mit 5 zu 3. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Kortbus und Frankfurt 3 Grad, Potsdam, Neuropin, Wittenberge und Angermünde 4 Grad und auch in Berlin 4 Grad. Heute Abend gibt es immer wieder Wolken und Regen bei Ties werden bis zu minus 2 Grad. Morgen ist es am Anfang freundlich mit ein bisschen Sonne. Später dann gibt es wieder mehr Wolken und zum Nachmittag auch Regen bei Höchstwerten bis 6 Grad. A11 Uckermark Richtung Berliner Ring. Zwischen Korinne und Werbelin sind beide Fahrtrichtungen gesperrt. Hier gibt es derzeit Bergungsarbeiten und die A19 Rostock Richtung Wittstockdosse. Zwischen Wagen und dem Dreieck Wittstockdosse, da fährt ein Schwertransport. Hier könnt ihr zu der Zeit nicht überholen, ansonsten sind die Straßen aber frei.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaos Radio Zeit, Chaos Computer Club bei Fritz, Konstanze, Frank, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, grüße euch ganz herzlich. 0331 77 97 110. Wir reden über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die uns seit einem Monat ja betrifft, so wir alle in irgendeiner Form mit anderen Leuten kommunizieren und vor allen Dingen auch was man tun kann, damit man es sozusagen ein bisschen schwieriger macht, seine Daten zu verschlüsseln. Wir haben schon gesprochen über Mails, über Mailverschlüsselungen wie SSL oder PGP. Wir haben gesprochen über die Möglichkeiten wie das beim Handy funktioniert. Da gibt es nicht all zu viele. Und wir hatten eben gerade mit Java, Quatsch mit JAP und mit Tor zwei Möglichkeiten zumindest die Internetverbindung einigermaßen zu verwischen. Und jetzt kommen wir zu Asterisk. Das ist eine Möglichkeit Telefonie, also Voice-over-IP-Telefonate. Und jetzt muss Konstanzin mir aus der Patsche hin.
Eigentlich muss ich diese Sache unbedingt Frank überlassen, denn er hat da heroisch im Selbstexperiment verschiedene Studien durchgeführt. Wir haben natürlich im CCC diverse Asteriske und wir selber benutzen die auch beide, aber Frank hat da echt so ein sportliches Projekt.
Zum Anfang, was ist ein Asterisk?
Okay, also ich fang mal an. Es gibt die Möglichkeit per Internet telefonieren. Eine Möglichkeit davon ist Skype. Das ist wahrscheinlich die bekannteste. Eine andere, die vielleicht macht ihr es in einer Firma mit euren Telefonen schon, wenn es sehr fortschrittlich ist. Möglicherweise habt ihr aber auch schon einen Telefonanschluss, der voice over IP basiert ist. Manchmal habt ihr das schon ohne es überhaupt zu wissen. Das läuft über das sogenannte SIP, also S-I-P Protokoll, was sich da jetzt so weitestgehend durchgesetzt hat. Und es ist einfach, ja, man hat keine feste Telefonleitung mehr, sondern benutzt das Internet. Also ihr könnt ja auch irgendwie Musik hören, Radio hören über das Internet. Also kann man auch telefonieren über das Internet. So und das ist dann mach ich dann in der Regel entweder am PC mit einem Kopfhörer, Mikrofon oder ich hab auch ein ganz normales Telefon, was bei mir auf dem Tisch steht oder ich hab dann so eine Wanderbox, die also dann mein analog Telefon in Voice over IP Gespräche wandelt. Und das Besondere dabei ist, dass ich also anders bei einem Telefonanbieter, da kann ich es ja auch machen, es gibt auch Call by Call, aber das ist sozusagen jetzt nochmal ein Stückchen weiter getrieben bei Voice over IP, weil im Internet kann ich mich ja wirklich überall hin verbinden. Das heißt also, ich kann mir zum Beispiel einen Voice over IP Anbieter in der Schweiz suchen, bekomme dann von dem möglicherweise sogar eine Schweizer Nummer, eine Schweizer Festnitznummer zugeordnet und verbinde mich dann aber über das Internet mit dem. Das heißt also, ich kann irgendwelchen Leuten eine Nummer, eine Festnitznummer in der Schweiz geben und das Gespräch kommt dann aber bei mir an über das Internet und für die Verbindung über das Internet wird ja erstmal nicht bezahlt, sondern ist es dann einfach, wenn jemand aus der Schweiz anruft, in der Schweiz in Nürnberg ist es einfach auch ein nationales Gespräch, also einfach ein normales Fernengespräch, kein internationales Gespräch, spart also auch schon mal eine Menge Geld. Das interessante dabei ist, dass also wir kennen jetzt die technischen Details für die Umsetzung von Voice-over-IP noch nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache, wenn man das sehr intensiv betreibt, kann man damit die Behörden schon deutlich verwirren, denke ich mal. Man kann das Ganze, das ist jetzt keine Sache, die jetzt ein kommerzieller Provider anbietet, aber wer jetzt ein bisschen technisch versiert ist, kann sich da mit Freunden zusammentun. Wir als Club haben das auch, so eine Infrastruktur. Ich persönlich hab das mal, um es einfach mal auszuprobieren, wie weit kann man das treiben, dass man sich also mehrere Voice-over-IP-Anbieter sucht, vielleicht noch einen eigenen Server betreibt. Man kann das auch über so dynamisches DNS zu Hause auch mal machen, dass man also selbst zu Hause einen eigenen Server hat und dann die Gespräche wild hin und her routen. Das heißt also, man kann sagen, viele Leute haben mittlerweile auch eine Festnetz-Flatrate, das heißt, die könnten einem dann sogar seinen Anschluss zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt, ich sag, ich komm jetzt mal aus dem Anschluss raus, denn mal wieder von woanders, geb jemand mal eine Nummer aus der Schweiz, mach dann einen Anruf Weiterleitung irgendwo anders hin. Und also man kann da ziemlich wilde Sachen bauen.
Ist das am Ende nicht so, dass man damit ganz wirkungsvoll unbedingt alle Verbindungsdaten verstecken könnte? Aber das ist natürlich so.
Man veranstaltet erst mal ein schönes Chaos.
Und wenn man zum Beispiel ein Stück dazwischen hat, wo man die Connection verliert, ist das eigentlich eine ganz gute Sache, um um die VDS-Wortsatenspeicherung rumzukommen.
Es gibt da noch die Möglichkeit, sozusagen private Netzwerke, Virtual Private Networks, VPNs zu machen, wo dann also auch nochmal die Daten auf der Strecke verschlüsselt sind. Das heißt, dass es dann auch wieder für niemanden möglich nachzuvollziehen, was da eigentlich rübergegangen ist über diese Leitung. So und wie gesagt, also je wilder man das hin und her strickt, je mehr Anbietermann involviert, mit mehr Freunden man das macht, desto unübersichtlicher wird das Ganze.
Das erhöht am Ende die Kosten für die Überwacher, weil sie natürlich dann jeden Schritt erstmal nachvollziehen können. Natürlich ist nicht wirkungsvoll, also das wollen wir auch nicht sagen, aber das ist eine Möglichkeit und wir versuchen halt beim Club auch gerade mal zu gucken, ja wie kann man das einfach machen für eine größere Anzahl von Leuten. Wir wissen, dass das im kommerziellen Bereich heute massiv eingesetzt wird, natürlich nur aus Kostengründen und also ich denke, da wird die Zukunft zumindest erstmal für die nächste Zeit hingehen. Immer mehr Asteriske.
Es gab ja auch in der letzten Zeit immer wieder diese Geschichte, dass es so eine SIM-Card-Tauschbörse gibt, dass man sozusagen, also ich schicke meine SIM-Karte irgendwo hin, kriege dafür die von jemand anderes und damit ist nicht mehr eindeutig zuordnenbar, wer jetzt da auf welchem Handy telefoniert. Das ist ja relativ schnell zusammengebrochen wieder.
Ja, also das war im Prinzip ja nur eine Woche am Netz, diese Idee mit dem Kartentausch, die wird auf privater Ebene jetzt zwar noch weitergeführt, aber der AK-Vorzeiten-Speicherung hat sich entschieden, davon Abstand zu nehmen und also wir at CCC waren doch eigentlich sehr froh, denn wir haben diese SIM-Kartentauschaktion eigentlich jetzt nicht sehr sinnvoll erachtet, einfach weil doch durch die eher kleine Anzahl, die der Karten getauscht werden und vor allen Dingen auch die Art, wie dort getauscht wird, auf keinen Fall tatsächlich in der Anonymität hergestellt wird und vor allem riesigendrohend für die Leute. Also etwa wenn man sich vorstellt, derjenige, der eben die eigene Karte dort bekommt, stellt irgendwas an und gerät unter Verdacht, dann kriegt man halt erstmal Ärger mit den Ermittlungsbehörden und für so eine Tauschkartenbörse müsste man die Leute wo doch erstmal sehr genau instruieren, wie sie es benutzen müssen.
Es gibt zu viele Wagepunkte.
Man hat schließlich bei einem Telefon die sogenannte E-Mail-Nummer, also eine Nummer, die das Telefon identifiziert. Eine nationale Nummer. Und die Leute müssten auf jeden Fall die neue Karte, die sie dort im Wege des Tausches bekommen haben, erstmal in ein neues Phone einstecken, sonst können sie ja schließlich gar nicht, sonst sind sie eh wieder identifizierbar und sie müssten auch ihre Telefongewohnheiten ändern.
Also wenn wir ganz kurz zurück, wir hatten ja mal Anfang Gesendung, hatte ich so ein bisschen dieses Bild aufgebaut mit diesem Netz, mit diesem Spinnennetz, dieses Software, wo man sich durchklicken kann, wo man diese ganzen Daten reinwirft. Und das wird ja da an dieser Tauschbörse, kann man es sich ja wunderbar vorstellen. Das heißt also, ich hab irgendwie ein Gerät, sozusagen eine Gerätekennung von einem Mobiltelefon. Dann sehe ich, okay, welche Karte war da drinne, wer hat sie danach gehabt? Ich sehe das und das heißt, ich kann also dieses Netz, dieses Tauschnetz wunderbar einfach mit dieser Software abbilden, mit ein paar Mausklicks. Und das ist eigentlich genau das Problem dabei. Und weil ich es ja auch noch dann zuorne, das heißt also, wenn ich davon ausgehe, dass mein Handy auch mit der neuen Karte dann auch wieder bei mir zu Hause liegen wird und mit den gleichen Nummern benutzt wird, also die gleichen Anschlüsse angerufen werden, so dann bringt es eigentlich nicht so viel. Im Gegenteil, es lässt sich mit so einer Software wunderbar ein gutes Bild erstellen, wer eigentlich gerade mit wem getauscht hat.
Dazu haben wir einen Anruf aus Berlin und zwar von Thorsten. Guten Abend, Thorsten.
Das Problem ist, ich vertausche oder verschicke meine IP-Adresse, ich vertausche meine Karte vom Pripyat. Was passiert, wenn Leute mit der von mir genutzten oder von dir verschickten Geschichte was anstellen?
Dann stellen die Bullen bei dir vor der Tür.
Ja, dann hast du das Problem und brauchst eine ziemlich gute Erklärung.
Also ist eigentlich auch diese Geschichte mit dieser E-Mail-Geschichte, dass ich über andere Leute was verschicke, genauso hin, vielleicht.
Also meinst du möglicherweise diese Tor-Geschichte, wenn du nicht andere IP-Adressen hast? Ja, genau. Ja, das ist richtig, da hast du recht. Also das hatte ich auch schon gesagt, wir hatten dieses Jahr eine große Durchsuchungswelle und es ist so, dass die Personen, die sogenannte Exit-Nodes betrieben haben, also quasi der letzte Punkt in dieser Kette waren, das war dann die IP-Adresse, die dann auch in den Protokolldateien aufgetaucht sind. Genau, der hat dann diesen Server hingestellt, hat gesagt, hier, ich finde das cool, will dabei sein, will das nutzen oder hier benutzt es. Und dann hat er eben morgens um sieben den Besuch bekommen, der Server wurde beschlagnahmt, war natürlich klar, dass da keine Logdaten drauf sind, weil das passiert einfach nicht. Es gibt Fallen bei diesen Tordiensten, fallen einfach keine Daten an, keine Protokolldateien, aber der hat halt erst mal den Ärger gehabt. Und da drüber muss man sich immer im Klaren sein. Deswegen machen wir das oder bieten wir das als Chaos Computer Club auch an, dass wir das sozusagen als juristische Personen das machen, dass wir diese Dienste betreiben und können das natürlich nicht alles selbst bezahlen, weil so ein Server muss gemietet werden, der kostet im Schnitt 100 Euro, möglicherweise ein bisschen mehr. Man muss ja auch mal einkalkulieren, dass mal einer irgendwie wegkommt oder muss dann auch mal im Zweifelsfall mal einen Anwalt bezahlen, wenn es irgendwo Ärger gibt. Deswegen versuchen wir das ja irgendwie durch Spenden zu finanzieren und bieten aber an, dass wir diese Server selber betreiben. Also quasi, dass da unsere Adresse, unser Clubbüro drinne steht, unsere Clubanschriften, dann könnt ihr da gerne Bronze um sieben aufgeben.
Wir haben einfach Routinen dafür entwickelt, weil wir eben selber Betreiber sind, wie wir dann mit so einem Anfragen umgehen. Nee, aber uns geht es auch darum, dass wir einen Pool bilden können. Also wir wollen versuchen, Leute, die eben nicht mehr privat sich trauen, quasi, dass sie sich an uns wenden können. Das ist so ein bisschen das Ziel der Sache.
Also es gibt ja natürlich neben den Privat-Usern, sag ich mal, Leute wie Rechtsanwälte, Ärzte, wir hatten es vorhin, Seelsorger, Pfarrer, wer auch immer, bei denen es wirklich dramatisch nicht nur in die Privatsphäre, sondern auch in die Arbeitswelt einschneidet, wenn ihre Kommunikationsdaten überwacht und ausgewertet werden, weil dann ist sozusagen weder das Arztgeheimnis, noch die Speigepflicht des Anwalts, noch sonst was gewährleistet.
Es ist sogar noch mehr. Es ist durchaus auch so, dass unsere Ermittlungsbehörden in Deutschland natürlich auch Anonymisierungsdienste benutzen. Das sagen sie auch ganz offen. Also es sind nicht nur die Vertrauensberufe, die wir so haben, die eben schon genannt ist, sondern durchaus auch die Ermittler selbst, die sich ja auch anonymisieren müssen.
Torsten, danke für den Einwand. Ich würde ganz schnell noch nach Lübeck schalten wollen, weil Michael steht hier und hat eine ganze Latte von Fragen. Hallo, Micha. Warte mal, ist Lübeck moin oder moin moin? Naja, weil ich habe mal gehört, wenn du sagst moin, ist es okay, wenn du sagst moin moin, ist es ein bisschen schwärzer.
Nee, dann magst du die Menschen eigentlich nicht.
Ah, das war die Oldenburger. Okay, Micha, schieß los.
Ja, wo wir jetzt gerade bei der Person waren, wer bleibt eigentlich verschont oder sind wirklich alle? Oder da sind wieder unbeliebene, alle unsere Abgeordneten außerhalb?
Die Abgeordneten sind ausgenommen, ja.
Also ansonsten, es betrifft natürlich erstmal jeden, also eine halbe Milliarde Europäer, jetzt nicht nur die Deutschen. Und also der, der kommuniziert ist erstmal natürlich dabei.
Also letztendlich kann der Telefonanbieter kann ja erstmal nicht wissen, dass es ein Abgeordneter ist.
Ja, aber wirklich die Dienststellen sind dann halt freigeschaltet davon.
Nee, nee, nee, also keine Blacklist, sie werden erstmal alle gespeichert. Und das Entscheidende ist dann, ob die Daten rausgerückt werden.
Genau, der Zugriff.
Ja, die, die noch eine Frage dazu. Was kostet eigentlich so ein Provider? Jetzt sag ich mal die Speicherung. Ich mein, sie haben sie ja zu Abrechnungszwecken, müssen sie ja sowieso speichern. Bei Fleetways entfällt das ja prinzipiell, aber das ist auch nicht dasselbe, was gespeichert wird.
Wobei, also was ich mir auch absagen lassen ist, also das Problem ist gar nicht mal das Daten speichern. Also ich wüsste, was irgendwie eine 500 Gigabyte Festplatte kostet, das ist nichts mehr. Das Problem ist, diese Daten tatsächlich auch, sag ich mal gerichtsfest oder beweisfest, also wirklich solide aufzubewahren und dann auch entsprechend diese Abfrageschnittstellen zur Verfügung zu stellen oder eben diese Prozeduren. Und es muss natürlich auch von juristischer Seite entsprechend begleitet werden, das heißt also allein die Kosten dann Juristen zu haben, der dann auch darüber wacht, was mit diesen Daten passiert. Das sind dann die Kosten, die wirklich ins Geld gehen.
Also es gibt natürlich eine gewisse Form von Entschädigung, die der Staat, den IS-Pista zahlen muss, und die Telekom-Modifikationsunternehmen, aber die Summe, die wir vorhin schon genannt haben, also dieser dreistellige Millionenbetrag, ist natürlich zunächst mal eine Investition, die die machen müssen.
Das ist für die Abfrage, ne? Da gibt es denn eine Entschädigung?
Nein, das ist sozusagen die Technik, also es ist ja nicht eine sehr ungenaue Zahl. Also das sind die Kosten für die für geschäftsfremde Zwecke installierte Technik.
Von welchen Datenmengen reden wir eigentlich, sag ich mal pro Tag oder pro Woche? Weil wenn ich überlege, was bei Google, da gab es ja irgendwo mal eine statistische Seite, wo Google mal gesagt hat, was für ein Traffic sie wirklich pro Stunde oder so haben.
Wir reden da glaube ich eher, wenn man es über das Jahr sieht, wir reden über Petabyte. Also das heißt, das ist der Schritt über Terabyte. Also im Jahr fällt da einiges an. Aber sicherlich die Kapazitäten bei den Anbieter sind heute auch schon hoch. Und es ist nicht mehr so teuer wie früher. Und es ist ja auch verteilt. Es fällt ja nicht an einer zentralen Stelle eben diese gesamten Daten an. Das wäre für den Staat auch nicht machbar. Sie müssen es ja eigentlich auf die Anbieter verteilen.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ein DSL-Anbieter, der muss ja jetzt nicht protokollieren, welche einzelne Webseite du klickst, sondern muss halt deine Einwahl protokollieren.
Ja, da haben wir im Vorfeld uns noch sehr intensiv darüber unterhalten. Wir sind nicht sicher, weil wir brasilitänischen Details erst noch in Erfahrung bringen können. Es gibt geteilte Aussagen.
Zumindest ein ganz großer Unterschied, ob ich URL speichere oder ob ich IP speichere.
Das ist richtig. Aber man kann, man muss schon sehen, dass auch die Betreiber ja Listen von IPs haben. Und auch das wäre sehr kritisch. Es ist unterschiedlich. Ich hab mich jetzt auch in Europa mal um mir sehen. Und da gibt es Wohlländer, die dieses konkret wollen. Also die Liste der angesurften URLs. In Deutschland können wir es einfach nicht mit Sicherheit sagen. Ich halte es persönlich nicht unbedingt für realistisch.
Wobei es da also nochmal wieder unklar ist, ob es jetzt der Serverbetreiber ist oder der Zugangsanbieter.
Dann ist die Sache eigentlich hinfällig, dass die jetzt die ganzen Sachen speichern. Weil da könnte ja auf dem einen Seite gleichzeitig eine linke Seite wie eine rechte Seite sein. Von einer politischen Orientierung. Dann ist ja auch hinfällig, ob da jetzt sich einer aufgeklickt hat. Dann haben die ja nur die IP. Dann wissen sie aber gar nicht, ob der zur rechten Szene gehört und vielleicht irgendwas plant oder was.
Die Idee ist, dass sie den Server beschlagnahmen, um den es geht. Und dann sozusagen da anhand dessen sehen, wo die Zugriffe waren. Wer zugegriffen hat über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und welche Seite er aufgerufen hat eben auch. Deswegen sollten auch verantwortungsvolle Webseitenbetreiber, Webserverbetreiber sollten ihr Logging einfach möglichst abschalten. Weil dann können die Behörden auch gar nicht in Versuchung kommen, einfach mal nachzufragen.
Man muss sich schon bewusst sein, dass die angesurften URLs heute in der Regel vier Tage bei dem Anbieter gespeichert werden. Das ist so die gängige Praxis, also für einen kurzen Bereich.
Michael, eine Frage kriegst du noch, weil sonst räumt die Zeit weg und Richard aus München hängt auch noch da und trammelt mit dem Fernseher.
Eine habe ich noch. Genau, Tor. Zwei habe ich noch.
Zwei kurze, los geht's.
Wie ist das mit Tor eigentlich? Wie sieht es aus? Wer hat Tor auch verpflichtet? Eventuell die hier?
Gute Frage. Gute Frage.
Ja, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Ich hatte noch nicht auf demselben Sender hier im RBB ein Gespräch mit dem Herrn Engers aus dem Justizministerium. Einer derjenigen, die das Gesetz zur Vorratszeitenspeicherung geschrieben haben. Und ich hatte die Gelegenheit, ihn gleich mal danach zu fragen. Oder auch, ob es in Zukunft geplant sein wird, die Anonymisierungsserver vielleicht zu verbieten. Denn technisch fallen diese Logdaten nicht an bei dem Tor Server. Und er wusste zunächst gar nicht, was ich ihn fragen wollte und sagte nur, ja, da steht im Gesetz, die müssen rausgegeben werden, dann müssen die rausgegeben werden. Und dann habe ich ihm also lang und breit erklärt, dass die technisch nicht anfallen. Und dann war, nachdem er so der Groschen dann fiel, seine Antwort im Grunde, ja, dann wird es natürlich verboten werden. Aber damit hat er natürlich nur gesagt, was der Gesetzgeber wohl in Zukunft planen wird. Wir beim CCC sehen es eigentlich momentan so, dass Anonymisierungsserver legal betrieben werden können.
Und wie sieht es jetzt eigentlich aus, wo wir gerade bei der wettlichen Geschichte sind, wie sieht es mit dem letzten Standsverfassungsgericht aus?
Hatten wir vorhin schon mal ganz kurz, also Sie haben sich jetzt geeinigt, wer zuständig ist oder wer welchen Teilaspekt der Klagen beantwortet, der der Klage bearbeitet.
Aber da ist natürlich die Frage, der Anonymisierungsserver ist da jetzt nicht angesprochen. Da geht es natürlich um viele wichtige, ganz allgemeine Fragen unserer Grundrechte. Klar. Also ich persönlich würde eine Wette machen, dass die gekippt wird.
Ich hoffe es. Micha, danke für den Anruf. Schönen Abend nach Lübeck. Und jetzt auch der Traum eines jeden Senders. Jetzt ganz von Norden, tief runter in Süden von Lübeck nach München. Hallo Richard. Du kriegst zwei Minuten.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage zu VPN Tunnelservices. Da gibt es ja so diverse Angebote, zum Beispiel von der schwedischen Piratenpartei Relax, nennt sich das und VPN Tunnel glaube ich aus England. Und zwar, wie, ob das irgendwie eine Alternative zum Beispiel wäre zu Tor, weil also gerade bei diesem Relax gibt es so ein Demo Angebot, habe ich mal ausprobiert und es funktioniert wunderbar, ist wahnsinnig schnell, also kein Unterschied und da wollte ich einfach mal fragen.
Prinzipiell ja, das heißt also, dass erst mal alle Verbindungen, die dahin gehen, dann sozusagen, ja, also du kommst ja auch mit deren IP Adresse raus. Die Frage ist, ob du denen soweit vertraust, dass die dann deine Daten entsprechend nicht rausgeben.
Okay, also das heißt, gut, den schwedischen Piraten würde ich da einigermaßen vertrauen.
Ja, aber nur ein eigener SSH VPN Tunnel ist ein guter SSH VPN Tunnel.
Okay, aber nicht jeder hat jetzt die technische Kompetenz dazu oder auch die Zeit, so was zu machen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also ich würde der Piratenpartei natürlich da irgendwie auch eher vertrauen als anderen Anbietern, aber dieses Vertrauen muss natürlich haben. Ende der Debatte, also so ist es nun mal.
Aber ist es ein guter Kompromiss vielleicht zwischen Sicherheit und Komfort, sag ich mal?
Ja, ach na ja, also komformäßig finde ich.
Also Tor ist schon ein Komfort, ist schon okay, ist halt nicht wahnsinnig schnell. Aber je mehr Leute mitmachen, desto mehr Server wir betreiben können, desto komfortabler, desto schneller.
Und wir sehen auch durchaus Möglichkeiten technologisch, wie sich das in Zukunft weiterentwickeln wird. Also es gibt halt im CTC auch durchaus zu den sogenannten I2P, also neue Projekte, wo man gucken kann, wie man anonyme Netzwerke aufbaut. Da wird sicherlich in Zukunft eine Menge passieren.
Und wir werden sicherlich auch an dieser Stelle im Laufe dieses Jahres noch das Öfteren darüber reden.
Wenn du dich dringend mal beteiligen möchtest, nicht wahr, such dir den Regionalkreis der CTC in der Nähe und schmeißt das Projekt an und programmiere.
Richard, wir hören von an, ich freu mich. Das war Chaosradio 131 heute zum Thema Ausbruch aus dem panoptischen Gefängnis.
Vielleicht noch mal eins, weil der Hinweis kam auch schon auf unserer Mitmachseite auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Das heißt natürlich nicht nur, dass wir jetzt alle ganz tolle technische Lösungen gefunden haben, dass wir uns jetzt zurücklehnen können und sagen, hey, macht doch eure Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Nein, das ist natürlich genau nach wie vor wichtig, dagegen zu protestieren, auf die Straße zu gehen, Briefe zu schreiben, mit Leuten zu sprechen. Diese Klage zu unterstützen, wenigstens moralisch dran denken, Daumen drücken, wie auch immer.
Mama erklären.
Mama erklären, genau. Also das heißt jetzt nicht, dass wir nur weil wir jetzt irgendwie...
Nur weil auf unserem Rechner Tor läuft, heißt es nicht, dass wir uns zurücksetzen und sagen, dann macht doch euren Scheiß alleine. Das wollte Frank eigentlich sagen, oder?
So ist es.
Alles klar. Ich würde gerne noch anmerken, dass unter Chaosradio.ccc.de diese und andere Sendung als Podcast zu hören sind. Wenn ihr euch zum Beispiel zum Thema GSM und GPS noch mehr anhören wollt, könnt ihr da gerne alles tun. Auch diese Sendung gibt es dort zu hören. Das Chaosradio gibt es wieder Ende Februar. Danke Konstanze, danke Frank. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight und Smith & Smart. Schreibt ihr, schraubt die Radios fest. Bis denn. Haben wir noch was?